bonjour venez vite je vais vous dire il
fables de jean de la fontaine le lièvre
et les grenouilles
vous connaissez nous nous non bonjour je
lis les salit tout le monde bonjour
casimir tu viens écouter la la fable du
lièvre et des grenouilles étaient très
gentils joli mais je ne peux pas j'ai
vraiment pas le temps à bout oui j'ai
reçu une lettre de ma tante adélaïde mes
cousins paris demain matin
alors il faut vous leur prépare un
énorme cube iboga palais je suis pressé
saluera tout à l'air bon alan fois ci le
lièvre et les grenouilles un lièvre en
son gîte
songez-vous tu t'es raviser tu viens
écouter la femme telle fable la sape que
je suis en train de raconter enfin non
non non non non je voudrais savoir si tu
n'as pas une très grande casserole pour
faire un gloubi boulga pour 15 personnes
qui mangent bien non je suis désolé j'ai
pas de grandes casseroles mais c'est une
catastrophe une catastrophe un étage ah
oui au début c'est ça elle y est bon en
son gîte songer car que faire des
excuses moi encore qu'est-ce qui est
encore quasi mise que tu as regardé le
ciel hier soir ouais pourquoi pas pour
rien pourquoi rien pour rien tu veux pas
écouté la fac qui me coupe deux fois
enfin tu me demandes et enfin tu
exagères c'est comme un incroyable je
l'aimais est incroyable coup de françois
tu tombe bien tu as vu casimir
aujourd'hui non non je n'ai pas vu
pourquoi tu sais il a un air très
mystérieux c'est pas grave c'est casimir
a toujours un petit air original où est
originaire l'original là c'est très
bizarre
il me parle de sa tante il me demande
une casserole si j'ai regardé le ciel
une coupe deux fois dans ma femme
enfin c'est insensé mais tu as peut être
raison je les regarde le tiens qu'est-ce
que je t'avais dit
qu'est-ce qui la fabrique avec ma chaise
un passage me le demande
c'est plutôt inquiétant tant qu'ils ne
transportent qu'une chaise sait pas
encore trop grave c'est quand même assez
bizarre
nous on est ce qu'abu calcul où il
aurait pu me le demander je ne t'énerve
pas ne t'énerve pas je pense quand même
on devra les huit ans défendra ce prix
qu'elles allaient les enfants venaient
voir avec nous à nos sites
non mais mais qu'est ce que c'est que ça
c'est peut-être une sculpture pour
monsieur disnat du gros attention ne
toucher à rien poussez vous voilà enfin
casimir j'espère que maintenant qui va
me donner l'explication c'est une
sculpture casimir mais nous c'est pour
aller attraper la grande casserole
refrain quelques casseroles mais enfin
celle qu'on voit le ciel dans le ciel de
soie quand il n'y a pas de nuages mais
qu'est ce que c'est que cette histoire
et enfin la grande casserole gtz une
grande casserole pour faire un plus beau
gars pour mais mes petits cousins qui
arrive de mal alors je pense celle qui
l'ancien casimir tu vraiment trop naïf
enfin coûte je vais te montrer ce que
ses casseroles tiens il dans casimir du
côté vraiment monté là dessus ben ouais
et alors n'ont fait que gémir
mais les pas de vérité de casseroles
dans le ciel enfin cholet vule expliqué
l'accusée notre hall tu vois ça c'est la
grande ourse qu'on appelle aussi le
grand chariot toi on pourrait même y
mettre les roues voyez alors là on
qu'est ce que c'est là bas c'est
l'étoile polaire il te permet de
découvrir la direction du nord alors la
nuit quand tu a repéré la grande ourse y
est bien dû prolonge ce côté cinq fois
cela te donne la direction de l'étoile
polaire qui la direction du nord ainsi
la nuit eh bien tu peux te diriger sans
boussole tu vois casimir n'y a pas de
casseroles dans le ciel pour préparer un
déjeuner pour technique
jean-françois j'ai vraiment été stupide
pour chariou m'a donné une idée un look
ou encore eh bien demain lorsque mes
cousins seront là nous attendrons la
nuit nous grimpons sur mon échafaudages
désolé je les emmènerai faire un grand
tour en chariot
[Musique]